I'll come back for another talk
um we have a pleasure of having Nana and
your parents talk to us about
correspondence coloring events
thanks a lot for the invitation to be at
this wonderful Workshop
um I learned a lot of new things during
this Workshop so it's great this is
Joint work with zenik who is at Charles
University
and uh
the talk is on correspondence coloring
which also is called DP coloring in some
papers so you might see this and it
opens as project postal but Stanek
doesn't like this name and as a as his
quarter I feel obliged to use the other
word the other name but
um
so this is going to be a generalization
of
list coloring and it's just a question
that we try to push through and
eventually we gave up and we think we
don't have the right bound so I thought
as a workshop
it might be a good thing to present to
you so you might have a better
understanding how to prove the right
well at least for us the right
conjectured band so let me just remind
you what
um
a list assignment Or List coloring is
so I have graph G
um a list assignment is just some
mapping
of uh so every vertex gets a list
which is some collection of
some subset of L colors
such that and so every vertex has a list
of available colors
and the goal is
color
vertices
properly
there's that for every vertex the color
you assigned to it is from its list
and the least chromatic number is
defined to be the minimum
size of the list you need to do this so
it's the minimum amount
such that if
every list has size
this L then
there's a
proper there's a coloring I will call it
l coloring
so no matter what lists you give
um if the list have size at least L I
can always properly color the vertex
okay so this is the list chromatic
number and clear and okay so I have to
mention that this was introduced by
visiting
[Music]
76 and also independently by erdosh
Ruben and Taylor
um
79 and I have done the mistake once of
not mentioning visiting and this was not
appreciated by Sasha costochka so I
should always remember that it's
independently done
by these two groups uh anyways so
clearly we have that the list chromatic
number is at least as large as the
normal chromatic number foreign
the other direction is very false in the
sense that there is actually no function
such that the least chromatic number is
at most uh F of chi of J and
um
an exercise is to take for example
complete bipartate graphs
they have arbitrarily large list
chromatic numbers but their chromatic
number is just two
okay so
um but let's uh look again what what
does this list uh coloring is actually
so it's just this assignment right so if
I have UV and let's suppose I have the
colors the list of Julius let's say one
two three and or B is let's say two
three four
then I can think about it as I'm given a
matching or forbidden uh forbidden
connections right so I could look at U
cross Lu
and V cross LV
and now so this would be U1
U2 u3
uh let's say you're four
and here I have a V1
I have V1
B2 B3
B4
um
and what are the connections I have
right so uh I'm not allowed to use uh
two on both of them so I have this
matching and I have this matching and
that's it right
so this is basically telling me uh and
we are given a matching
partial matching
um
matching
between uh
elv and
ulu
and it's a specific one meaning that I
have the same color used however now the
for the correspondence coloring what you
do is you say let me just do any any any
matching
okay so I it doesn't have to be between
the same colors
so that's the definition of the
correspondence
assignment
which is now a pair
um
where
l
is a list assignment
G and M is
a collection of matchings
okay
so m is like Union of all it's like each
I have like this collection of matchings
in where it is in all the edges runs
over all the edges and uh
yeah so m e is some matching
between
q l u and blv
where
is The Edge you'll be
so instead of having this picture now
I'm allowing
anything to happen
and now you can do the rest as before
and you can Define the chromatic number
the correspondence chromatic number of a
graph
as
minimum l
such that for any
um
LM correspondence assignment
it's possible
color
preaching
so no matter what how you do the
matchings
as long oh I need to say size of the L
is at least off
if the size of the list is at least l no
matter how you put this matchings I can
always color it properly such that each
vertex takes
um
take the
pixel color from its list and none of
this
um none like the curse none of the
Forbidden structures are there
that making sense
I guess I didn't really say
oh I didn't really say what coloring
like how I'm color like yeah I
understand what
so just in the picture
um
well my list of my list of colors are
gonna be the the union so I'm assuming
like I have the colors one two three
four
plus when you construct this hyperhead
crap yeah
yeah I take like everything it's so it's
here I'm thinking of it as a partial
matching
right and then when I'm looking at the
the
um like I mean I changed like at this
point I'm changing it like I'm saying
maybe uh sort of in the green
foreign
what I want is that okay so I guess
to have a color I should say Ellen color
this means so if I L I'm coloring
because I mean is
um first uh every color of the vertex is
in the list of that vertex
second
[Music]
um
if
uh UV is an edge
then uh if I look at the if I colored
you with CU and I colored B let's see B
then this is not
in the matching M Yogi
what is the role of colors here sounds
I'm coloring the list so okay so I'm
coloring it's the same all colors
yes you can use I can say that just you
uh if you want just
um you'll see and and PC
but the point is that um
you can assume that everyone has the
same set of colors
they want and you can I can say that
this the set of colors let's say has
size exactly and yeah okay so so
does that make sense so one maybe an
example
is let's say let's take like C 2K in
particular let's take
um let's take C4
so the C4 you can always list like you
can color it with two colors and you can
also list color with two colors right I
can just color
um let's say cream and uh
let's say everyone has color
now let me show you an assignment where
you can't do the same for uh
correspondence coloring
um so I could take
let's say a few one
um
it's um
B1 B2
and let's say x one
two and double one
and now I so the first few I will just
do it
normally
here I'm gonna mess things up and then
I'm gonna put this matching now you
can't color this with two colors right
because
let's say you start with this maybe
maybe you decide that you are going to
color this with one or green so I'm
thinking of one being green
the other one being red
okay that tells me that on this vertex I
have to use the second color right
and then it also tells me that here I
have to I can't use this one I have to
use the red
but now I really am stuck because I
can't use red here I have to use this
but there is this restriction
so they are different
in fact one can show that for the
correspondence coloring of c2k is
actually three
so it's about like so this were not um
the correspondence coloring was not
introduced just for the sake of having
one more type of coloring it was
introduced as a generalization somehow
it helped to prove something in
structural graph Theory by generalizing
this coloring to the correspondence
coloring it made it easier
but now we don't yeah we don't know as
much I guess as we wish about this
coloring so what we know is
some maybe some bounds what what's known
so some
results on okay
so if I have maximum degree I mean this
like if Max decrease Delta
um
then you can do the classic greedy
algorithm and get that the
correspondence coloring number is it
most Delta plus one
um
it's known that if G is triangle free
then what we know is that for list
coloring number
we know that it's one plus little of one
Delta over Ln Delta and this this is
known by results of Molloy
2017 and also by Johansson
um from 96 moloi improved the constant
to one Johansson did it for C and for
correspondence coloring it's known that
the same bound holds
um
this is a result by Bernstein
okay what's also known is that if G is
planar then the bounds we have are
actually close to each other so the list
coloring of planar graphs is at most
five this is known by a result of
Thomason
um
and um
what do you mean ah this one this is
where this is where you are saying
um
if you have triangle free
[Music]
um
I think I think so now listen to Sierra
has found that yeah I think that there
is a Biblical constant maybe it's two
um
the the actual bound is the same I think
there's like a concept of perhaps that
maybe is
um
um and for this guy it's almost five
this is proved by trojak
and
um also
okay
um and then there's some improvements in
case
um
[Music]
so
um okay so if you have that the guard
it's planar
plus uh Gert is at least five
then
this is at most three and
the first one does not a chromatic
number is at most three so it's Again by
the same people
um okay now from lower bounds what's
known is that
for um
so the lower bounds are going to be
different
and
this is proved by
um
for list coloring is proved by along
the list coloring number so at this
point I'm thinking about a g of average
degree
see
and the less chromatic number is known
to be Omega of log d
this is a result of alone
and for correspondence chromatic number
it's Omega of D over log B
so by Bernstein
okay so we do see some difference
between this
um but surprisingly the question that
okay so finally the question we studied
was what's the
a chromatic number of the random graph
correspondence chromatic number of the
random graph and uh here what's
we do know that the normal chromatic
number the usual chromatic number is n
over log n and here I'm ignoring the
constants those are also known
um
and then for the list chromatic number
it's also known
to be um
the same order and over log n by con
and then
we don't know
what's the correspondence
number
is it an over login
and this was a question by Sergey norin
and what we can prove is that it's and
it's at least bounded by n over squared
log n
okay
so
foreign
we think that the right conjecture sorry
we have a we conjecture that this should
be the right bound the N over log n and
the reason why we think that is because
you can think about so
the conjecture is
that it should be actually an over login
is the right round
um
and the reason for this is because it's
supported by the two extreme cases one
is
when you assign the
when you assign this matchings as in the
list coloring case it's an over login
you can think about the other extreme
case to assign random matchings
um like as a like the assignment is just
random matches in that case you also get
an over login
in fact that um yeah so even if you take
KN and uh take random assignment
each matching random matching storage
or list of size
again
there exists
um
you can color
so here I mean by in this correspondence
I think
that's why we think that the the because
the two extreme cases are supported
probably this is the right one
okay so let me say a few words about
heartbreaker's conjecture and how it's
related to this and then I will say a
few words how we actually prove this
um but uh the proof is using gloves
local Lemma and some probabilistic tools
um it's nothing too fancy it's like lots
of dieted lovers locals so after whose
talk where there's like zillions of
purple pixels yes this is quite simple
um okay so let me say a few words about
that
um
I can ask a few questions about them yes
there's lots about sorry not that about
that one so the results about triangle
tree graphs so they're in the spirits
they're supposed to shine
yeah
so since there's a work
about that for hyper graphs for high
uniformity are there hypergraph
generalizations of those upper bounds
I had
a list coloring of hypographs
or what about the original
I mean you can
run towards like there is one way you
can Define what
um like
um
you don't see a monochromatic
Edge right where like in every edge of a
uniform like at least one color but
there are at least two distinct colors
so you could also Define it differently
so
depending on which version of coloring
you are looking listen
it was about the planar graph so since
you mentioned how bigger conjecture is
there a
generalization of
the bonds for the this chromatic number
and yes
[Music]
um
so the last four foreign
chromatic number
no because this one I'm just well okay
actually you're right in the sense that
the print is similar because yeah it's
very good yes sometimes you maybe just
say one one word about this so how you
would prove this is so you could look at
um you could look at any set
let's say
S
I will call it any neighborhood said
this is a set which lies in some
neighborhood of a vertex
okay and
um what I will see here okay is some
assignment right so everyone has some
lists right and the property that I have
so here this expands to something which
we call a cover graph that everyone now
becomes like
um so this vertex U becomes U1 U2 dot
dot u l u and so on
um and the property I have is that if
I'm looking at like two vertices
um well everything is adjacent in KN so
between any two vertices I'm seeing
um
a random uh random matching right
so uh in a way what what you can say the
probability of the search being there is
one over the size of of the list right
so this this thing actually behaves like
a random graph so I can study these
neighborhood subgraphs which are the
main object that we study because we try
to
um take like some partial coloring of uh
of the graph and then we say okay
actually not so many bad events happen
so we can readily uh go up so looking at
the vertex and its neighborhood and how
the colors behavior is important but
indeed so if you zoom in here then you
are just looking at the basically gs1
over l so the same method works yeah so
I mean
either goes to Azuma or Jensen
we use concentration so you're right
that we use the answer but what I'm
saying it uses uh love us local Lemma
when I previous result
and also it uses concentration as well
so maybe I should have not done this
because
so um yeah that's correct
okay
um
where where was I uh is that okay okay
so for uh what's hard because conjecture
and what's the what's that question that
um
so this says that
if G is
KK minor free
um then the chromatic number of the
graph G is at most K minus one
and this is true for
up to K Atmos 6 and there's tremendous
really difficult work to prove that this
is the case
um the linear Hardware conjecture says
that um
okay maybe we can't really prove this K
minus 1
but maybe
um it's true that the chromatic number
is of uh K or in other words uh HG where
this is the hardwicker number HG is the
hardwicker number
it means that it's the largest
okay such that
KK is a minor
of G
okay
um what's known about this is that
um well there has been some improvement
very recently
um
so
we know that
um this um
so let me call like the bounds that I'm
going to prove let me let's say that FK
is the
um
let's say that FK is the maximum
G is k k minor three
and what's known is
uh from like a work of Costa Chica and
Thomas I'm from 80s it's known that it's
uh of order K squared log k
and this is because graphs which are
KK Miner free they are K Times Square
log K degenerate
that's how you get this bound
um
and then recently in a
it was proved
um
by um look pastel Sergey norin and uh
jisha song in 19 that this bound holds
[Music]
um
and then there were
possibly many many papers by Luke
and eventually this is the convergent
sequence to we are stuck at uh klog
okay I buy Luke postel and Michelle
dockert
I guess I think actually I say 20 it
might be already published
uh okay so the same conjecture if you
ask for linear list you can ask the same
question for list coloring it's not true
in the sense that you are not gonna get
this K minus one
okay so
um for
the hot records conjecture is false
false for
um
for example there exists K5 minor free
graphs
with
the list chromatic number five
um
and uh but you can ask the same question
regarding the the bound right you can
ask the linear uh whether this the same
bound FL k
if I call it the list coloring bound
um and what's known there is that flk is
K log log K to the sixth this is a
result by pastel from 2020
.
um
but actually there was some conjecture I
don't know what it was
um why it was uh conjectured but there
was a conjecture by mohar and kawara
bayashi that instead of this K minus 1
it's 3K over 2 which seemed pretty
random and that was disproved so by
Raphael Striker showed that
um
actually this should be at least two
and I think people believe that this two
also should go up like it's it's maybe
not tied to the two
um like the constant not in terms of
like not as not higher order just a
constant
okay uh so this is what's known for the
least hardwicker uh conjecture like in
terms of uh the bounds uh for
correspondence coloring nothing is known
except this trivial bound
here because the same proof works you
just take the degeneracy and it's still
true
but our results
to support that
so for random graph it's true so I will
say it in a second so F correspondence K
is
um just K squared log k
by the same bounds
by Costa Chica Thomason
and nothing else on
any better around so in particular uh
trying to generalize these things are
hard to correspond this coloring
so let's open
but what I want to say is that it's
known that for the hardwicker
number for GNP is n over uh squared log
n
this is a result by Bola Bosch
um Kathleen
and ardosh from my teeth
what I mean by a hardware number is that
the largest click in GMP or pfix is of
order n over squared login
[Music]
um and because we are proving that the
chromatic number of GNP
the correspondence number is also of
this order
um
it supports the the linear Hardware
conjecture for the correspondence
coloring that the correspondence
coloring of graph is of the hardwicker
number of Gene supports
everyone
which is a conjecture
is that does that make sense
okay okay
[Music]
bonds are
kind of going Beyond
I mean it's
we can say it's generalization
you can think about it that way
approvements
quite extremely and
um
the structure of this album when like
you're you have like this urge and
there's like
um
yeah I don't want to say it's a general
consistent it's not I like a conjecture
it's conjective it's not tight so I
wouldn't say it's realization
um I think I know why you look confused
I think I miss this type of order and
over Square building so now
okay uh and then I have some time so I
will try to give you some idea what uh
how does this proof go
um for the random graph
okay so
um
what we prove is actually like the key
Lemma
the following
let me write it and then say what this
is um
so we'll proved that for any
real
me
which is Atmos Delta one where this is
the max degree
of the graph G
um
if
graph G is the rich then
which I haven't defined which I will do
in a second then the correspondence
coloring number is at most of Delta over
B
um
and what's this be a richness it's
it connects the number of independent
sets of a graph
um so I will say what this is so G is be
a reach
[Music]
if
um for every neighborhood subgraph
F of G
um so basically f is in some
neighborhood
or B
um let's say
number of verses is s
um satisfies
number of independent sets
is at least twice
um
as choose at most B so I'm going I'm
taking the binomial coefficient up to B
um unless
this is too small
so the way to think about it is that I
look at some neighborhood subgraph
F lies here and I'm saying that unless f
is very small there are many independent
sets in F
okay
and the way this is going to help like
why this independent sets are going to
be helpful is because when we are doing
this um
um coloring so like I want to be
when we are doing this like a partial
colorings of the whole set we are trying
to uh like really sometimes have to do
recoloring and if I know that the graph
is be rich then if I remove some colors
and then now look back and say how many
uh are there many choices of
Independence that's how I put are there
many ways to recolor then if there are
many independent sets then I know that
there are many ways to recolor that's
the that's the idea
um one thing is that so this is the main
um and this is the we use the love us
local Lemma and concentration
inequalities to prove this kilemma
[Music]
because I'm thinking about the special
piece of like the final three crafts
[Music]
all the neighborhoods
is that really rich
yeah so so let's do the triangle three
case
so let's say example
um let's say GEOS triangle three
um
and let's see what do we get
okay so if I'm triangle free and okay so
there's a Delta which is
not the idea
um
and the maximum degrees Delta and I want
to claim that
G is some constant times uh log
Delta which ah are you saying that what
I wrote here is not
are you complaining about the my
notation of Delta to D little o one yeah
so let's see why that's true so let's
take any F you know so for any vertex p
i take
a subgraph of the neighborhood then it's
Edge less right so
um the number of independent sets is
um actually two to the the size of
the vertex set so it's 2 to the s
because f is Ageless
and now um I can do two things like
this will be at least twice as at least
B
if s is bigger than 2B
okay and otherwise if s is less than 2B
then I will have 2 to d s is at most go
to the 2B and I'll say that in that case
it's less than this bound Delta
with the one third which means that if I
choose B
log to be less than log Delta one third
which means P less than
uh
okay so B is less than 1 6.
so indeed this is true so for triangular
free graphs it's actually trivial to
show that it's B rich
um
or uh
well
so for triangle free graphs actually you
can't get better because there is the
lower bound which is Delta over log
Delta so I can't do better than that
and in fact uh maybe the motivation of
the stock is maybe the spear richness is
not the right notion but so far all the
no all the bounds that are in the
literature actually boil down to the
spear richness which we introduced like
we can we can basically recover all the
possible all results that are known
already which I'll state by real
richness but for the random graph we can
prove that the random graph is square
root login reach
and it's tight and we can't do better
which means that this bound cannot be
like this approach is not gonna help us
to get potentially the right and over
log inbound so let me like that
um
let me
like that so
um
you can prove that GNP is
squared log n Ridge
and of course whenever I say GMP is
where Logan rich I really mean uh
asymptotically almost surely and this is
tight
how to see
[Music]
um
um and then we can recover
a bunch of results
most results
prior richness
I guess if you are rich you can recover
anything so
suppose we can prove is that if we can
prove that for example if you have
chromatic number at most R plus one then
G is C log
Delta reach
um
and then
if if you're if you are R plus one click
free then G is C log Delta over R log
log Delta reach
um
and some other results but the point is
that all of this bounds were already
known and we are just recovering them
um
okay uh maybe a few words how this Lemma
is proved
um
so there's a there there's this
um maybe most of you have seen like this
nice little Lemma by sharer which says
um
if um
The Grouchy is kr3 then
um like there are at least
um IG over too many
independent sets
of size
[Music]
um
one over two R Times log of ifg
over
log log ifg
and a similar thing is true for uh you
can instead of having care free now you
can go to Rich graphs can say that if
she has
[Music]
if G is
as Max degree Delta
and is the reach
um
and uh
let me just be a bit weak number of
independent sets of G is at least
some
some constant times Delta to the one
third then there are many there are at
least
IG over too many
independent sets
of size at least be
so you can get a lot of independent sets
of size at least B
so
um this is useful when we are doing some
recoloring
[Music]
um
foreign
just say okay so basically the proof is
this picture and lots of technical stuff
but uh pick a uniform
um
partial coloring
of
um
G
and uh now you look at this event
so for every vertex you I'm gonna look
at the so the bad events are going to be
one is a u which is going to be the one
that
um the event that
who has
less than Delta some Alpha many
colors available
and what I mean here by availability is
that in this partial coloring a lot of
its neighbors have used uh
like colors so what is left is that so
if I have you and I have so image U is
not colored at this point
so you is not in this let's call it B
here is not in
Roman enough
and when I look at its neighbors
and if I see a Vertex here which is
already covered colored by say some
color then this color is not going to be
available at you
so Au is uh the bad event that there are
less than Delta to some constant many
available colors
to you
and the other bad event is going to be
that
okay
um
and that U has
at least
um Delta to the alpha many neighbors
let's say your crime such that AO Prime
doesn't happen
Okay so
and U Prime is also not colored yet
so the way to think about the second
event is that
um U has many many vertices who still
have to be colored many neighbors who
still have to be colored they are in the
same shoes and you so that's also bad
right
because one thing could be if there are
not so many colors available to it but
the other thing could be that his
neighbors are also gonna still have to
be colored and there are many of them
which can create a problem
s
actually them all I think yeah yeah
indeed so now when I'm in it so now when
I'm I guess I have three minutes I told
you it will be shorter
okay
um and now
um here is the idea so if I look at the
vertex and I look at its neighborhood
and then I look at the
second neighborhood
like a neighborhood and then third
neighborhood
now I look at the rest
so anything that happens in the rest
is only dependent right so if I look at
any vertex here
and I look at it like the events ax
or BX
they are only dependent on this and like
the second neighborhood and the first
neighborhood they are not dependent on
you and then you
because
the event ax here talks about his
neighbors right
and the BX talks about the neighbors of
the neighbors
right so you only get to this level so
you and and you stays there which means
that now you can uh
the intuition is that you can call like
recolor you and and you the first
neighborhood as many times as you want
and what we prove is that
um I mean this is the
the main like
local Lemma think is that the
probability
um sorry
that Au happens given that none of the
events ax and
the X happen for any uh set of let's say
that and Z Prime
where Z and Z Prime are here
at most one over some constant Delta
Cube and the same is true for bu
and um basically what I'm saying is that
um like we are using this Lobster that
it love us local Lemma the number the
size of the dependent sets is just Delta
Cube because I just have to remove the
first three neighborhoods and now uh
if I look at any vertex U and I want to
say what's the what's the probability
that this vertex is going to be bad with
respect to one of the bad events
conditioned on
the stuff which is outside it's a
dependency set is small and the
smallness here like if you remember the
lobster that is something like 1 over 4D
and I need at most the uh like events
that I need to remove
which is the size of the neighborhood
I think I have to stop here so thank you
but I'll take
[Applause]
you're using a lobsided are you using
this in the random injection model
um
so what that what that means is that I
say that so there are some events right
and for every eye
um so this is all the other I know the
lopsided for all the applications
well
the random publication so we are the
underlying renderedness is not
true
computation
well we our Randomness is coming from a
partial coloring of um of the of the
graph
so partial assignment so and you can
think about
you can think about it as
[Music]
I I guess I can think about yourself
presentation right because I'm just
looking at the vertex set and then
assigning everyone some pair
so this one so what do you mean by
persons
and then fixes those claws repeatedly
right so I just
so what I mean is that uh I'm thinking
of a partial like I pick a
any uniformly random like partial
coloring and now I'm thinking okay uh if
I can prove that this holds right that
the probability that um that
um like Au and bu is small it means none
of the bad events happen but now what
does this mean that I can I can finish
the coloring readily right because what
did I show that every vertex has at
least Delta to the alpha many colors
available and every vertex also has less
than Delta to the alpha many neighbors
that needs to be covered which means
there's I can just like readily color
everyone
so yeah
if there is no more uh questions